[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit aber tausenden von jahren ist der
mensch vom himmel im weltall fasziniert
seit menschengedenken beschäftigt sich
unsere spezies mit all den objekten am
himmel lässt sich von ihnen leiten und
beeinflussen wenn du nur ein wenig
darüber nachdenkst werden die dafür
sicher zig beispiele einfallen wäre
seehandel oder die navigation nach den
sternen mit hilfe des astrolabium es
möglich gewesen wäre die entwicklung der
komplexen landwirtschaft im
mittelalterlichen europa möglich gewesen
wenn den zeichen des kosmos keine
aufmerksamkeit geschenkt worden wäre wie
hätten sich technik und wissenschaft
ohne science fiction literatur
entwickelt und diese wiederum ohne dass
die sterne die fantasie und
vorstellungskraft unserer vorfahren
beflügelt hätten wusstest du zum
beispiel das bereits im zweiten
jahrhundert nach christus der antike
schriftsteller logisches moser in seinem
werk wahre geschichten darüber
fantasierte zu den sternen zu reisen und
außerirdische lebensformen zu treffen
erstellte sich sogar interplanetare
kriege vor
juli an gilt damit als erster science
fiction autor der weltliteratur aber er
blieb nicht der einzige wir alle kennen
namen wie cyrano von bergerac daniel
defoe und natürlich schön aber keine
sorge in diesem video geht es nicht um
die geschichte der astronomie oder gar
um fantastische science fiction dann um
die knallharte realität von prof
[Musik]
am 20
dezember 2010 unterzeichnet präsident
donald trump den verteidigungshaushalt
für das folgende jahr ein vollkommen
normaler und alljährliche vorgang
diesmal erhielt das entsprechende
haushaltsgesetz jedoch einen passus da
alles andere als normal und alljährlich
war freunde an diesem tag gründete
präsident donald trump auf der andrews
air force base die uss die united states
space und jetzt fragst du bist sicher
ging es da um mehr als nur eine pr
schlagzeile hat es so etwas nicht schon
mal gegeben also pläne den weltraum zu
militarisieren 0
heute werden wir all diese fragen
natürlich beantworten aber zuerst werfen
wir wie immer einen blick in die
geschichte
[Musik]
der wettlauf ins all
ja genau da gab es schon los die 1950 er
jahre der kalte krieg zweier supermächte
im wettlauf um die vorherrschaft im all
der kampf zwischen dem kommunismus und
dem kapitalismus der sowjetunion gegen
die usa den startschuss zu diesem
wettrennen feuerte am vierten oktober
1957 die sowjetunion ab an diesem tag
wurde das hat selbst bot mit 1 in die
umlaufbahn geschossen und liebe freunde
diese silbern glänzende kugel hoch oben
im himmel versetzte das ernst der bürger
und das wohnen eines völligen
schockzustand denn der knall kam völlig
unerwartet und zu allem überfluss war
eigentlich der einzige nur weniger als
einen monat später kann die udssr und
der nächsten weltraum premiere league 2
mit dem das erste tier der erdgeschichte
in die umlaufbahn geschossen wurde die
arme hündin laika welche traurigerweise
nach wenigen stunden im augenblick wegen
überhitzung und stress verstand aber
erst im darauf folgenden jahr 1958 waren
die usa eigentlich in der lage auf den
vorsprung des ob jetzt adäquat reagieren
mit dem start ihres ersten satelliten
explorer worden
[Musik]
kaum hatten die amis aber mit ihren
ersten satelliten und der gründung der
nasa 1949 doch noch irgendwie die kurve
gekriegt linken dies soll jetzt 1961
noch eins drauf und versetzen die welt
nun gänzlich in erstaunen am zwölften
april 61 schlug der junge juri gagarin
als erster mensch in den orbit und nach
seiner rückkehr wurde er als
internationaler superheld empfang nur
wenige wochen später folgte ihnen der
amerikaner alan shepard aber natürlich
auch diese hunde hatte moskau gewonnen
die sowjetunion hatte beim wettlauf ist
also ganz klar die nase vorne
ihr gelangt eine mission nach der
anderen das verlassen der erdumlaufbahn
die unbemannte landung auf dem mond und
sogar die erste mission zur venus nun
alle räume war die erste mission zur
weichen landung auf dem mond das
sowjetische raumschiff landete ganze
drei jahre bevor der erste mensch einen
fuß auf die mondoberfläche setzte es war
teil eines langstrecken programms der
sowjetunion um mehr über den mond zu
erfahren und alles deutete damals darauf
hin dass für immer gelten sollte den
kommunismus in seinem weltraum wettlauf
halten weder ochs noch esel auf
doch dann am 25 261 geschah etwas was
die karten in diesem spiel für immer neu
mischen würde
[Musik]
an diesem tag hielt präsident john f
kennedy eine rede vor dem us-kongress in
der eine neue nationale priorität
verkündete menschen genauer gesagt
amerikanische männer auf dem mond herum
spazieren und danach sicher wieder auf
die erde zurückkehren zu lassen und
dieses ziel musste unbedingt vor ende
der 1960 er jahre erreicht werden nun
wir alle wissen wie die geschichte
ausging am 20 juli 69 betrat neil
armstrong den mond mit seinem riesigen
schritt für die menschheit
[Musik]
ok wissen aber nicht hier um über
allseits bekanntes zu sprechen sondern
um herauszufinden welchen politischen
und geschichtlichen einfluss dieses
wettrennen ins all hatte was müssen wir
uns also dazu ansehen
der schlüssel zum verständnis dieser
ganzen geschichte besteht darin ein
blick auf die hauptunterschiede zwischen
dem sowjetischen und dem amerikanischen
raumfahrtprogramm zu werfen und dabei
stoßen wir gleich auf eine sehr
interessante sache
[Musik]
obwohl die sowjetunion ihre
weltraumprogramm schon sehr früh
militarisiert hat wurde dies von den
amerikanern anfangs nicht mehr so dass
stark in betracht gezogen
in den jahren 57 und 58 appellierte us
preisen aber der selbst früher im
militär general war an diesem ort
spitzen wohl gar nicht und christoph die
welt kommission zu einem projekt der
wissenschaftlichen zusammenarbeit
zwischen den beiden ländern zu machen
und nicht zu einem militärischen
wettrennen er hatte damit jedoch kein
erfolg die sowjets zogen einfach ihr
eigenes ding durch und dennoch haben die
amerikaner bald darauf die nasa als eine
vollkommen zivile und unabhängige
agentur gegründet und nicht nur das dank
des vom us kongress im jahr 48
verabschiedeten gesetzes und
amerikanische wissenschaftler viele
freiheiten bei der erforschung des
weltalls in der raumfahrt das genaue
gegenteil galt in der udssr deren
weltraummissionen wurde streng vom
ministerium für allgemeinen maschinenbau
kurzem kontrolliert das im unterstand
dabei direkt dem
militärisch-industriellen kommission des
ministerrats der udssr
[Musik]
so aber selbst danach ließen die
amerikaner nicht locker dies soll jetzt
doch noch zu einer zivilen
zusammenarbeit warum zu kriegen
präsident kennedy unternahm den nächsten
versuch die welt programme im geiste
einer politik der entspannung und
zusammenarbeit der konkurrierenden
weltmächte zu führen dies war in derart
wichtig dass er darüber sogar in seiner
ersten rede als präsident sprach last
beide seiten versuchen die wunder der
wissenschaftsstadt ihrer schrecken zu
beschwören
lassen sie uns gemeinsam die sterne
erforschen die wüsten erobern
krankheiten ausrotten die tiefen der
ozeane erschließen und die küste und den
handel fördern
john f kennedy
aber nix da kurz stellte sich taub wie
eh und je
wahrscheinlich sagte er sich dass die
sowjetunion aufgrund ihres riesigen
vorsprungs einfach keine zusammenarbeit
nötig habe tja aber dann gelangt ist den
vereinigten staaten 1962 john glenn in
die umlaufbahn zu bringen
und plötzlich begann die sowjets sich
doch noch für alle mögliche
zusammenarbeit mit den amerikanern im
weltraum von interessiert zumindest das
terrain für mögliche kleine kooperation
wurde erkundet die nasa griff die ich
natürlich sofort auf man einigte sich
zum beispiel darauf wettervorhersagen
miteinander zu teilen und ja ich weiß
dass jedes heute als unbedeutend
erscheinen mag aber bedenke bitte welche
symbolkraft in selbst in einer solchen
kleinen zusammenarbeite erzfeinde
steckte ganz zu schweigen davon dass das
alles vor dem hintergrund einer fast
paranoiden atmosphäre der geheimhaltung
in der udssr geschah
der chefwissenschaftler der sowjetunion
ins disler keltisch präsident der
akademie der wissenschaft sei zum
beispiel nicht ein warum um alles in der
welt man seine erkenntnisse mit dem
klassenfeind teilen sollte obwohl es nur
um meteorologische daten gehen keltisch
war so was wieder voldemort das
sowjetischen wissenschaft der akademiker
keltische selbst war gegenstand einer
paranoiden geheimhaltung viele jahre
lang war der name keltisch ein
staatsgeheimnis er war nur als er
anonyme chef theoretiker der kosmonaut
ick bekannt
[Musik]
und als ob all dieses misstrauen noch
nicht genug wäre kann dann auch noch der
hardliner bresche und tat bei den
gesprächen mit den amerikanern gehörig
auf die bremse
leonid breschnew war bevor er ins
politbüro eintrag beauftragter für alle
fragen der militärindustrie und liebe
freunde leonid war sich sicher dass die
unter ist dass er einen klaren vorteil
hatte und dass es keinen sinn hat er mit
den amerikanern zusammenzuarbeiten warum
sollte man ihnen helfen wenn man sie
durch schlagen und in den boden rammen
konnte aber es stellte sich heraus dass
er falsch gelegen hatte ba-chef hatte
einen großen fehler begangen denn schon
wenige jahre später spazierte neil
armstrong auf dem mond herum und rannte
selbst eine kleine flagge mit stars and
stripes in die oberfläche des
erdtrabanten und danach liebe freunde
sollte die stimmung im kreml nie wieder
die gleiche sein wie zuvor
natürlich nutzten die amis die situation
sofort skrupellos aus um dies soll jetzt
wieder in richtung friedlicher
zusammenarbeit zu drücken und ihr
schlüssel zum erfolg waren gregory peck
und gene hackman wer das hast du richtig
gehört zwei hollywood schauspieler denn
bei einem gemeinsamen treffen der
wissenschaftler im jahr 1970 legten die
amerikaner ihren sowjetischen kollegen
etwas vor dass diese äußerst verlegen
machen würde
[Musik]
den hollywood-film verschollen im
weltraum dieser film handelt von drei
amerikanischen astronauten die im
weltraum verschollen waren und
schließlich von sowjetischen kosmonauten
gerettet wurden dies soll jetzt tauchten
natürlich zunächst ihren augen nicht
warum sollte hollywood derartiges
sowjetpropaganda produzieren aber
philipp händler damals präsident der
akademie der wissenschaften der usa
machte sein sowjetisches gegenüber ist
dies laut keltisch auf den eigentlichen
springenden punkt des films aufmerksam
dass es nämlich im falle einer kritische
situation wieder im film gezeigten
notwendig wäre
miteinander kompatible systeme zu haben
um im weltall gemeinsam handlungsfähig
zu sein denn außer amerikanern und
sowjets war da draußen ja niemand ohne
zu hilfe zu kommen und philipp händler
hat ist damals mit der hilfe hollywood
tatsächlich geschafft keltisch den graz
träger der sowjet paranoia zu überzeugen
diese einigung war nicht nur eine
symbolische sondern eine historische
mitten im kalten krieg als beide mächte
ihre nervösen sänger am atomaren abzug
hielten brauchten diese beiden großen
feinde östlich des lebens
auf diese weise wurde das
kooperationsprojekt zwischen den apollo
und zusatzprogrammen ins leben gerufen
ein doping module entwickelt und 1975
sollten beide raumschiffe einander
ankoppeln friede freude eierkuchen bis
man liegend rolle der zwanzigste januar
1981 kam an diesem tag würde die
weltraum strategie der vereinigten
staaten eine kehrtwende um 180 grad
nehmen denn an diesem tag kam ein neuer
mann ins weiße haus
[Musik]
der krieg der sterne
am 20 januar aus 181 betrat ronald
reagan das weiße haus mit einer
scheinbar verrückten idee das nukleare
arsenal alles erst verein das erste
unions sollte vollkommen obsolet gemacht
werden genau beträgen wollte die die
jahrzehntelange militär strategie bei
der supermächte einfach über den haufen
schmeißen
er wollte die schnelle revolution statt
langer evolution aber wie um alles in
der welt wollte er das anstellen wie
sollte die gesamte sowjetische nuklear
streitmacht in einen haufen harmloser
strohhalme verwandelt werden nun die
antwort ist ganz einfach mit hilfe von
[Musik]
aber nein diesmal geht es nicht um
hollywood filme im märz 83 stellten
nämlich die strategic defense initiative
sdi iphone besser bekannt als die star
wars initiative
ihr ziel war es sowohl auf der erde also
auch im weltraum ein system aufzubauen
das in der lage ist einen sowjetischen
atomangriff abgefangen und unschädlich
zu machen klingt gehen ja ich war aber
noch mal so einfach geht das eigentlich
gar nicht denn in wahrheit hatten die
amis am anfang keinen blassen schimmer
wie sie das alles eigentlich konkret
umsetzen sollten
das zielt die wissenschaftler und
experten aber nicht davon ab milliarden
hypothetischer vorschläge zu machen
von laserwaffen die auf dem boden und im
weltraum installiert sind bis hin zu
verschiedenen arten von raketen und
abgassystemen so zum beispiel kleine
stationierten abfangraketen namens
williams auf diese weise wollte gegen
die sowjetische nuklear stark macht
obsolet machen so dass die udssr in
offensiver und defensiver hinsicht
völlig ungeschützt wäre das war
zumindest die offizielle version oder
wollte reagan mit diesen
größenwahnsinnigen plänen du musst einen
riesigen bilder abziehen nun eigentlich
machte diese real keinen großen
unterschied denn die einzige sache um
die es ging war was die sowjets glaubt
und freunde ich kann euch versichern
dass sie dieses ganze es 3 und star wars
theater ganz schön nervös gemacht hat
die sowjetunion glaubte dass das große
technologische potenzial der vereinigten
staaten wieder mal die oberhand gewonnen
hatte und sah in rails aussage eine
echte bedrohung
vielleicht sollten wir einfach aufhören
uns vor sd 1 zu fürchten
natürlich können wir dieses gefährliche
programm nicht einfach außer acht lassen
aber wir sollten unsere besessenheit von
diesem programm überwinden sie setzen
auf die angst der udssr vor sdi in
moralischer wirtschaftlicher politischer
und militärischer hinsicht sie verfolgen
dieses programm um uns zu erschöpfen
gorbatschow in einer rede vor dem
politbüro im märz 1986
[Musik]
und ja gorbatschow hatte den nagel auf
den kopf getroffen
fast alle in krimml waren von reggae
star wars programm total besessen
denn falls regen nicht geblufft haben
sollte hätte dies schlicht und einfach
das ende der atomaren abschreckung und
des kalten krieges bedeutete und dieser
war schließlich der letzte trumpf der
betonkommunisten im wettbewerb mit den
wirtschaftlich überlegenen kapitalismus
ich soll jetzt fühlten sich also total
in die enge getrieben und wolken regen
treiben nicht einfach tatenlos zusehen
sie erhöhten also ihren einsatz 1987
startete vom kosmodrom baikonur unter
dem tarnnamen mehr 2 also reden 2 das
waffenstarrende militär raumschiff polos
und zu diesem zeitpunkt hatten ist die
usa noch die bürgerschaft ein einziges
ass déi system in den norden zu bringen
die story jetzt hatten sie also in der
entwicklung überholt ausgerüstet mit dem
skiff laser und dem kaska raketensystem
sollte tradings die raumschiffe einfach
abschießen bevor sie über stationiert
werden konnten
dumm nur dass die kommunisten den
allergrößten feind ihres vorhabens
vollkommen übersehen hatten ihren
eigenen totalen verlust jeglicher
realitätswahrnehmung glaube ja
trust
[Musik]
wenn die vorgaben für das projekt waren
vollkommen angst getrieben und derzeit
haben unrealistische psychologische
kriegsführung sein blog waren also
aufgegangen denn paulus war der arzt
monströs und schwer geraten und sein
diplom im orbit derart kompliziert dass
ist nach dem abtrennen oder trägerrakete
seine orbital geschwindigkeit nicht
erreichen konnte abstürzte und sang und
klanglos im pazifik versenkt und damit
hat der regen nun ein beispielloses
druckmittel in der hand bei jedem
treffen mit gorbatschow stichelte er ihn
zynisch mit seinem star wars programm
auf den bilateralen gipfel in games im
jahr 85 auf den gipfel von reykjavik 86
auf dem washingtoner gibt 87 und auf dem
moskauer 80 die sdp erwies sich in der
tat als das ultimative druckmittel für
verhandlungen
george shultz us-außenminister unter
rolle trading und selbst im golfshop
persönlich den bluff durchschaut haben
mag so war er dennoch von seinen kano
ihnen militärs und politbüro kollegen
getrieben immer mehr in die rüstung und
militarisierung des weltraums zu
investieren dieses quantitative
wettrüsten konnte die udssr deshalb gar
keine kampf gewinnen und so führten
diese gewaltigen sinnlosen
militärausgaben verbindung mit
allgemeiner misswirtschaft
umweltverschmutzung reaktorkatastrophe
von tschernobyl und so weiter zum
wirtschaftlichen und schließlich zum
totalen zusammenbruch des systems und
damit war das ziel von reagans star wars
programm eigentlich erreicht star wars
selbst schien nun überflüssig geworden
zu sein und obwohl die formel 1 gestellt
wurde das budget des programms nach dem
fall des ist das war drastisch reduziert
was das also ist das konzept des
weltraums als schlachtfeld tot und
begraben
ganz und gar nicht denn nur elf jahre
später kam ist noch viel viel dicker der
januar 2001 würde einen weiteren
wendepunkt in der raumfahrt politik der
usa darstellen und diesen brachte kein
geringerer als donald rumsfeld künftige
verteidigungsminister unter george bush
und damals schon vorsitzender des
verteidigungsausschusses er warnte den
kongress vor einer neuen gefahr die
vereinigten staaten stünden am rande
eines neuen pearl harbor
als teilhaber im weltraum aber von was
fabulierte dieser mann da war er
paranoid geworden oder wollte er einfach
nur seinen freunden von der machen lobby
eine neue cash cow besorgen nein hört
jetzt genau zu
[Musik]
die space force
vorne nach den neuesten verfügbaren
daten der juniors kunst törns seite ist
verfügen die usa über 1300 27 satelliten
im orbit und ein drittel davon gehören
der regierung oder dem militär
kein anderes land verfügt person viele
satelliten wie die usa und das mit
deutlichem abstand um die eine
vorstellung zu geben wovon wir sprechen
nach vorliegenden schätzungen verfügt
russland über rund 169 und china über
362 und meine lieben freunde der
einfluss dieser amerikanischen
satelliten auf unser tägliches leben ist
immens es vergeht kaum ein tag an dem
auch du nicht eine oder mehrere von
diesen nutzt wenn du einen über obst mit
dem flugzeug fliegt eine überweisung
über die website einer bank tätig ist
und so weiter und so fort aber wenn du
dir vorstellen kannst geht es dabei
nicht nur darum ein ähnlichkeiten für
die zivile welt zu schaffen im
militärischen bereich des satelliten zu
einem schlüssel instrument geworden
kommunikation navigation aufklärung
raketen erkennung zielfindung und
einstellungen um es klipp und klar zu
sagen die kriege der gegenwart und der
zukunft werden vom weltraum aus geführt
[Musik]
und wie die boxwelt kommission im jahr
2001 bereits hervorhoben als sie vor
einem möglichen fall havers szenario
weltraum warnte könnte ein koordinierter
angriff auf us militärs erhielten die
wichtigste armee der welt tatsächlich
blind und unbrauchbar machen wie würde
man seinen drohnen kontrollieren woher
würde man wissen was an einem bestimmten
ort vorsicht rät bevor man so
bodentruppen aus setzt die würde man mit
diesen gruppen dann überhaupt kulisse
paradoxerweise ist dasselbe daraus
konzept das einst der größte trumpf der
usa gegen die sowjetunion war für die
heute allein übrig gebliebene weltmacht
eher beunruhigend eine abhängigkeit und
diese angst ist nicht unbegründet in den
letzten jahren haben sich länder wie
china als fähig erwiesen satelliten
mithilfe von paketen zu verstören ohne
dabei arg ins schwitzen zu kommen
[Musik]
tatsächlich darstellt peking im jahr
2007 im rahmen einer demonstration der
stärke einen seiner eigenen wetter
satelliten mithilfe einer
mittelstreckenrakete eine rakete ohne
sprengladung die durch einfache
kollision mit dem schlitten seine
zerstörung bewirkte und hier ein kleiner
fun fact bei dieser kontrollierten
kollision entstanden mehr als 3000
fragmente die heute in form von
weltraumschrott die erde umkreisen kein
anderes von menschenhand begangenes
ereignis im weltall hat derart viele
trümmer erzeugt wie diese eine operation
jetzt musst du dir aber vorstellen dass
aufgrund der extrem hohen
geschwindigkeiten mit der diese trümmer
im weltraum zirkulieren selbst kleinste
partikel eine große gefahr für
funktionierende satelliten raumstation
oder kicken bedeuten können aber das war
noch lange nicht alles im jahr 2030
china eine neue anti satelliten ins all
aber diesmal mit viel größerer
reichweite sie flog etwa 18600
meilenweit und näherte sich dann us
satelliten an die sich ihnen dieser
orbitalposition bewegen china behauptete
natürlich ist handle sich nur um ein
rein wissenschaftliches experiment
nichts worüber man sich sorgen machen
müsse aber heute wissen wir dass das was
hier ein jeden tag demonstrierte im
grunde genommen ein leistungstest zu
einer neuen waffe war der song ding 2 in
der bodengestützten anti satelliten
rakete mit der fähigkeit eine hohe
erdumlaufbahn zu erreichen das heißt ein
objekt in mehr als 20.000 meilen
entfernung zu zerstören
[Musik]
und diese ereignisse dieses fest
beantworte von vor zehn jahren wieder
hallen space teilhabe und genau aus
diesem grund verfügt barack obama eine
des jahres 2014
das budget für verteidigung im
bundeshaushalt aufzustocken und zwar
ordentlich so und was ist mit putin
hatte er die ganze zeit nur tatenlos
zugesehen wie sich china auf einen
möglichen weltraum krieg mit den usa
vorbereitet nein ganz und gar nicht im
jahr 2017 als tramp bereits im weißen
haus saß startete russland einer rakete
aus der ein satellit heraus kam aus der
dann auch bis zu zwei weitere satelliten
kamen
tja liebe freunde typisch russisches
matroschkas danebengehen niedlich aber
um mit weit es geht ihm nicht darum
niedlich zu wirken denn dieses
satelliten begann nun manöver zu
vollführen die es ihnen erlaubten ihre
umlaufbahn zu verändern uns damit ein
für den feind völlig unberechenbare flug
verhalten an den tag zu legen der
perfekte schutz also gegen
abschlussversuche vom boden und das ist
noch nicht alles
bei einer weiteren gelegenheit folgte
ein anderer russischer satellit mehreren
satelliten der usa und ihrer verbündeten
einfach so als übung aber natürlich muss
man kein einstein sein um zu kapieren
dass diese fähigkeit wichtig ist wenn
ein satelliten zerstören will
und wie reagierte trump auf all das nun
obwohl in den usa historisch gesehen
alles was mit dem weltraum zu tun hatte
unter die hoheit der us airforce also
der luftwaffe feld reaktivierte trump im
august 2009 10
reagans ehemaliges weltraum kommando und
das war nur der erste schritt
noch im selben jahr ordnete trump die
gründung der usf also der united states
space mit trotz 20.000 soldaten ist
dieser neue zweite armee für die
ausbildung im hinblick auf mögliche
verteidigung szenarien im zusammenhang
mit satelliten zuständig übrigens tragen
diese 20.000 soldaten schön ordentlich
tarnuniformen da sie sich ja noch am
boden befinden und erst wachsen sich was
die denn so den ganzen tag da treiben
also stellt zum beispiel vor dass ein
us-kommando gerade eine spezial
missionen durchführt bunte just in
diesem moment fällt das lied mit dem es
mit der kommandozentrale verbunden
aus genau dann trete die uss in aktion
und würde dem kommando 1 19 zu weisen
sollte das lied infolge eines angriffs
ausfallen würden sie darüber hinaus
untersuchen wie die stirn fried außer
gefecht setzen oder was du dich
zerstören könnten dennoch muss man
feststellen dass es derzeit keine klare
und abgestimmte version dessen geht was
die us sf einmal sein wird
[Musik]
es scheint dass die am meisten
akzeptierte vision eine lite space fonds
nach art der küstenwache wäre die dass
wir verantwortlich wäre sowas wie
möglich eine sicheres weltraum umfeld
für kommerzielle satelliten der usa und
gewährleisten so aber china und russland
spielten ihrerseits auch einen starken
trumpf aus sie sagten den amis wenn ihr
nicht wollt dass wir waffen im all
stationieren dann lässt uns doch ein
internationales übereinkommen treffen
den wir alle beitreten müssen doch die
antwort der vereinigten staaten darauf
war ein kategorisches nein
sie argumentierten damit dass man doch
gar nicht überwachen könne ob das
abkommen von allen eingehalten würde und
das ist die stationierung von anti
satelliten raketen am boden er gar
nichts verhindern könnte aber was denkst
du würdest du an johns stelle ein
solches abkommen unterzeichnen im
vertrauen darauf dass die anderen länder
ist schon respektieren würden
oder würdest du er alle verfügbaren
ressourcen dazu nutzen um als erster die
technologische überlegenheit zu
erreichen
wie immer sind wir auf eure kommentare
äußerst gespannt wir hoffen dass wir
dieses video etwas gebracht hat falls ja
gebt uns auf einen daumen hoch und
unterstütze uns in denen du bist mit
deinem freund heißt und vergiss bitte
nicht dass nicht jede woche neue videos
hochladen werden also verpasst kann es
unsere updates abonniere unseren kanal
und klick auf das symbol um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden macht gut und
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]